all right Randy
Randy uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I'm from Los Angeles
California
what part South Central yes
tell me about your family growing up
um I was a only child for eight years
my father died when I was three I'm
sorry my mother remarried they had two
daughters together you know but we were
my youngest sister were eight years
apart
I mean it was um
my stepfather was basically he was an
[ __ ]
um he didn't want me but he wanted my
mother and uh my mom was real passive
and she she's not good on her own so she
gotta let it let him do what he wanted
to do and um
he uh he was very interesting a little
abusive uh mentally physically but you
know I made it through I've been on my
own size 15 he kicked me out the house
really what'd you do at 15.
um hustle I tried to go you know I tried
to go to school in the morning time and
you know hustle all night long but
um I'd be sleeping in class all the time
so teachers kind of were on me about
that so I had to choose between money
and living in school and uh money went
out school was not for you no
unfortunately
you're living on the streets
um the friends bouncing around I'm just
trying to make it I'm eventually you
know I mean I take care of myself it had
probably my own place but yeah initially
it was just bouncing around couch to
couch um
just like wherever whatever I can do
does you have a long-term goal or I had
I didn't know what I was going to do
um I honestly didn't think I'd be making
it even past 18. so thinking long term
was not even something I could even
fathom at the time
what'd you do
sell drugs for the most part I mean
robbery here and there but most of them
it's just selling drugs you stay out of
trouble
for the most part I mean I didn't get
caught does that mean yes yes you're
asking for trouble yeah I was lucky I
guess you could say
you joined the military at some point
yeah um it just so happened a friend of
mine and I were sitting outside smoking
some weed one day and a recruiter walked
by and he made it sound like it was the
best thing to sliced bread I mean I had
didn't know anybody in the military knew
nothing about it
um but at the time I mean it it sounded
like a it still gonna save my life
um so I went I was going within a week
where'd you go
I was in the Navy
and do you go overseas at all
training purposes here and there but I'm
all stationed in Pennsylvania how long
were you four years four years
and you came back and did what
um
back to Hustler uh yeah I mean I hadn't
graduated high school I still didn't see
I thought I would be able to go in and
get a job that I could use on the
outside and I went in for training for a
particular job and when I got to my
first Duty station they didn't have the
it was a mix-up in the paperwork they
didn't have their job available so I had
to learn bombs and guns on the job and I
couldn't really use that because I got
out so I was kind of stuck yeah so I was
in Atlanta
um
and the night before I was about to go
back to Los Angeles I just got out
I bumped into some friends of mine at
the club that I grew up with and found
out there's a couple of my other friends
were coming out the next day and um so I
stayed I was I never left three years
um and we just we did the most you know
he was telling bring a weave bring her
pills he could buy guns out there with
fake IDs and sending it you know we were
just doing a lot it was it was uh it was
a good time I could say it's in Atlanta
oh yeah yeah how's Atlanta compared to
L.A it's kind of like L.A you know this
is like a smaller La in a way because
you have a lot of transplants you got to
colleges out there
um but it was a good time I mean we got
strip clubs you got money you got women
from all over the place I mean it was it
was a good time like I have to say so
you like to buy the companionship of the
ladies sometimes yes yeah it's um to be
quite honest it's a lot easier uh dating
and get to know somebody and I'll I just
I don't like that part you know so and
plus there's no guarantee that you're
gonna get anything you know I mean
especially exactly what you want so I
find a lot easier just to go ahead and
um I'd rather pay up front and so we
both know what we're there for and
there's no um there's no mistake about
it if you had long-term relationships
outside of the streets yeah I'll try it
I have but
um I mean I still did this dish I would
dip in the streets at the same time you
know it was just um
like I said it's just a whole lot easier
and plus it's um
you could do and get whatever you want
and sometimes you can't get that at home
and variety is
yes always available right very much so
very much whatever you like it's out
there
how often do you partake in this
um
let's say uh as much as I can I mean
let's just say um you know we maybe once
twice a week you know something like
that depending on how money is or
whatever the case may be
I don't know about Atlanta but in Los
Angeles some of the girls are beautiful
here oh yes oh yes you do pretty good I
mean it's like I said lots of choices so
um you can't it's hard to go wrong
but I mean this is you know you get well
they try to steal from you or you know
it's playing games and you know they're
trying to hustle you and that kind of
thing so you got to watch out for that
yeah they're still Hustlers oh yes very
much so
you ever get develop feelings for any of
these girls
um
you try to keep yourself from doing that
I mean what you what you did with
somebody on a regular basis which is you
know I like to deal with somebody at a
regular basis sometimes because it's
it's easier to trust them too exactly is
that you gain you kind of have a rapport
with each other
um so
and when you're having sex it's hard not
to bring emotion into it so sometimes
it's it can happen it can happen but you
got to watch yourself it's it's a it's a
slippery slope I should say these girls
aren't meant for that no not at all and
they're not looking for that they're not
looking for it right and the people that
they work for don't want them
oh that
hold it how old are you I'm 47. 47 do
you have kids yes
where are the kids
um actually um I have custody of my 10
year old he lives with me
so you're raising him yeah
and and you support yourself now how
um well the I get money for the military
oh you do and that's enough to survive
that
just about just other things to maybe
help uh sometimes sometimes sometimes I
mean you know you do what you have to do
is it's it's it's survival
um
it's
it's a certain way of living you know
that you just
you have a different mindset excuse me
than most people do
do you ever have any uh crazy stories
with the girls
um I mean I've been chased by pimps you
know shot at that kind of thing
um I've had girls that that have
feelings and wanted to leave and I had
you know kicked out on the door and just
asked a girl and drag her back out you
know things like that
um been robbed of course you know my
parents down that kind of thing
um but not too bad not too bad
that's that's about the worst of it I've
never been um you know I've had girls
you know put knives on me uh oh one's
actually just stabbed me with the key in
the shoulder before uh trying to get
away with some money you had what uh she
stabbed me in the shoulder with the key
oh really yeah
uh she was you know trying to get away
with my wallet but um that's about the
extent is there something exciting about
it's getting girls this way the
adrenaline of it all yeah it's
um you know you never know what you're
gonna find you know you never know who
it's a new person it's it's the unknown
it's dangerous that too I mean because
you you could get Rob killed I mean who
knows what might happen
um it's just the unknown it's just the
The Thrill of the unknown I should say
and where do you guys typically go you
get a room
yeah I don't like being out on the
street I'm too I'm too big for the car
I'm not really keen on that you know
maybe a blow job here and there every
now and then but for the most part I
like to be able to get a room
you ever get STDs any diseases luckilies
no but I mean I use condoms yeah so yeah
because I don't there's no way that you
can trust what goes on on the street
do you prefer this
I prefer it is myself rather than just
having a steady girlfriend I mean I look
at it like this
um you meet a girl you know you take her
out you date yeah you take it to the
movies you take it to dinner
whatever the case may be buying some
gifts I mean you're just paying for it
regardless but there's no guarantee in
regular life you know and there's a
guarantee
when I you get somebody off the street
so you don't have to worry about that
and that's the part I do like because I
like to be able to get what I want
are drugs a part of your life uh
sometimes yeah
and the drugs are part of the girl's
lives oh most of them usually it
definitely drugs alcohol
um you know eat the meth uh cocaine
sometimes it's just a party yeah for you
guys right oh yeah oh I mean you try to
make it a party you try to have some fun
I mean you got to just paying for the
time I mean you want to make the most of
it
um you know I don't partake in
everything but you know some things I do
do
do you think humans are meant to be
monogamous
um
no
no I don't I mean me being a man is just
you wouldn't you have that want that
need
um sometimes if it's just something
different you know some you just get
that animal urge inside you no you
should drive down fig and you see how
many women yeah I mean who have naked
all naked I mean just waving at you
smiling at you calling come here come
here you know jump in your car please
yeah exactly exactly it's hard to resist
you know especially when you you know if
you've never done it before you know
some people are so afraid or so scared
they don't even they they never try but
I mean once you once you start it's hard
to stop
yeah I think even I think that becomes
addictive for some guys too oh yeah oh
yeah
said that guarantee satisfaction
what's your favorite kind of girl
um
I like Spanish women a lot they're
they're very I want to say spicy but you
know they're um passionate passionate I
should say I enjoy that very much
it's funny how you'll find white guys
that love the black women yeah yeah I've
noticed that a lot if you find black
guys who like the the white women yeah
yeah a lot of the Mexican guys like
the black girls oh yeah oh yeah it's
like a
yeah it's like you want to try but but
you're not used to you know but you
don't normally get you know it's like
going to a new restaurant trying the
food that you've never had before that
kind of thing
do you have any regrets oh most
definitely most definitely what's your
biggest regret
um my biggest regret you know is uh not
finishing school not having that
it would have been nice to have a
regular normal life you know just doing
that go to school you go to college you
know I play sports and I was pretty good
I mean I could have definitely went to
college on a scholarship and things like
that but
um life hasn't been easy you know it's
been up and down and you know that's
that's one of my biggest regrets did you
have good Role Models as a kid no mom I
mean it was just my stepfather and he
was not a good role model at all
um and other than that
that was it I did everything else on my
own after that you know it was just me
making mistakes you know learning along
the way just doing the best I could but
when you when you start out with no
information it's hard to uh to get
things right you know what I mean I mean
my life would be a whole lot different
otherwise as I said my father hadn't
died how'd you lose your dad I had
cancer
um but he was young it was sudden and um
you know his hit my mom High School
sweethearts they tried for eight years
to have me all that kind of thing but I
know my life would have been different
if he hadn't died but he can't control
these kind of things yeah
Randy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
it's a good question
um
I say
the most important
be a man of your word
it's it's it's do what you say
don't make promises you can't keep
and
you have to look out for yourself
you got to take care of yourself
yeah I just have to say that that'd be
it all right Randy thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem have some
fun this weekend Oh I will thank you
thanks